on va bien sûr revenir sur l'événement
majeur samedi 17 novembre à 8h30
l'événement majeur c'est bien sûr les
gilet jaune on va maintenant faire donc
le point sur tout ce qu'il ne fallait
pas manquer ce week-end sur les gilet
jaune dès 8h30
il avait lancé la première journée de
blocage on va on a tout résumé en vidéo
pour vous regardez ce week-end tous les
médias ont parlé de l'est gilet jaune
gilet jaune gilet jaune gilet jaune et
gilet jaune samedi 17 novembre ce ne
sont pas moins de 280 2000 personnes qui
ont bloqué route et lieux stratégiques
dans plus de 2000 points partout en
france sur les réseaux sociaux on parle
même d'un million de personnes des
français très nombreux bien décidés à
faire entendre leur colère
la rapide tour des taxes de tous deux
des roses de les chances de tous on en a
vraiment ras qu on en a ras-le-bol de
nous prendre à la gorge
regardez regardez notre peuple regarde
et vous vous êtes en or regardez à
l'échelle du banyuls convient toute
cette mobilisation extraordinaire aura
eu l'effet escompté faire parler de la
hausse des taxes liées au carburant et
plus généralement de la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat des ménages les plus
pauvres
hier soir le premier ministre edouard
philippe réagissez à ce mouvement sur
france 2 c'est pas quand ça souffle
qu'il faut changer de cap
si le bilan militants est une réussite
du côté de l'organisation c'est bien
plus discutable sur la présence des
forces de sécurité privé au public de
nombreux endroits ont été laissées aux
mains de quelques manifestants mal
intentionnées ou mal organisé bilan plus
de 400 personnes blessées dont 14
gravement une femme a été tuée en
haute-savoie renversé par une voiture
sur un barrage routier et 282 personnes
ont été interpellées par les forces de
l'ordre
la mobilisation a connu son apogée
samedi mais hier et aujourd'hui certains
citoyens rester mobilisés partout en
france
voilà c'est vrai qu'on en a beaucoup
parlé bien sûr gagner on va revenir sur
tout ce qui s'est passé encore parce
qu'on a plein d'image des gilets jaunes
est ce que vous comprenez vous le
mouvement des gilet jaune et qui a été
impactée par ce mouvement
samedi et dimanche est-ce que ce
qu'odile verdès moi je le comprends et
en fait c'est le mouvement de la
spontanéité c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire celle ci a pas de leader
c'est pas concertés il refuse d'être
récupérés et c'est très bien parce
qu'ils sont irrécupérables c'est les
gens qui se lèvent et qui disent on en a
marre c'est pour ça qu'ils nous touche
parce que c'est chacun d'entre nous ces
gens là chacun avec son histoire qui se
lève donc ici on fait pas de politique
mais ces gens-là il souffre il faut
vraiment les écouter les entendre alors
je vous dis à 281 7000 participants
comptabilisés sur plus de 2000 sites
malheureusement il ya 400 blessés 1 ou
le savez 14 blessés graves
28 policiers et gendarmes motards
pompiers ont également été blessés 282
personnes ont été interpellées pour 157
garde à vue et on a peu avant 9 heures
on a pu voir les images d'un
automobiliste qui a foncé à grasse sur
un policier qui était sur la voiture
regardez c'est l'une des images de ce
week-end qui a vraiment fait le buzz
regarde
alors il ya beaucoup de gens aussi qui
disent qu'ils sont contrôlés gilet jaune
et ne savent pas contre qu'il proteste
difficile de réfléchir avec un qi
d'huitre alors c'est ce que dit
quelqu'un kunselman moi j'étais d'accord
avant qu'on se fasse agresser sans
raison en allons faire nos courses mes
enfants sont traumatisés
voilà c'est dit il ya des gens qui
disent a également valérie mais c'est
effectivement ça le problème puisque
comme effectivement la force est aussi
la faiblesse de ceux de sol aux langues
comme il n'y a pas de leader et que la
contestation elle elle recoupe
énormément de colère différente elle
agrège des colères différentes et
ensuite les gens ne savent plus
exactement pour qui ils sont contre qui
ils sont et y compris entre gens qui
sont sur le sol homme un même point de
vue c'est dire que parfois on a vu des
personnes qui ne se qui ne se
comprenaient pas alors qu'elle disait la
même chose parce que le ton monte parce
que la colère monte parce que ils sont
dans une situation de précarité et on
comprend bien sûr will daniels c'est ce
qui avait été annoncé c'est qu'en fait
comme il n'ya pas d'encadrement que les
manifestations sont normalement on doit
les déclarer à l'avancé et il est très
tôt le samedi matin il ya déjà eus je
vous présente le jeu
[Applaudissements]
alors est-ce que vous avez été gêné vous
est-ce que vous avez benjamin que ce qui
est plutôt bien c'est qu'ils ont laissé
toujours le passage
ouais c'est vrai voulait passer ça
serait plutôt classe mois à paris
c'était pas il y avait un pas énorme et
je trouve que c'est très bien d'avoir
respecté ce qu'il voulait passer même si
quelques débordements pour le coup
d'oeil
comme il était incapable de dire si le
train d'être impactée s'il allait
bloquer des voix ou les routes il sut
pas les jeux devaient justement arrivé à
pont de beauvoisin là où est la cellule
accidentelle la jeune femme qui a
français et qui a foncé dans la foule
exactement au même moment jean michel et
si je me fais un truc sans passer pour
le dernier des laîches boules parce que
là je le pense vraiment c'est que j'ai
vu une vraie différence entre balance
son poste vendredi vous avez reçu notre
charlie mais aussi des gilets jaunes les
autres tokyo notamment samedi soir n'est
pas couché qui était complètement
déconnecté de l'actualité total alors
qu'à vous receviez les gens qui font
l'actu et ça ça m'a j'aime pas vous
flatter mais là ça m'a stressé quand
vous êtes vraiment très important le
taux qui fait parler aujourd'hui c'est
vrai je prends merci en tout cas c'était
c'était le but et voilà tous les gens
qui veulent s'exprimer sont les
bienvenus dans balances ton post aller
9h38 samedi un journaliste faisait
tranquillement un duplex à balma en
haute garonne
sauf que derrière l'oreille ou lui il y
avait un gars gardez bien qu'ils portent
un t-shirt parodique de la chaîne info
bfm tv regarder
je me plais
alors regardez alors voilà nous y voilà
donc mais fm tg et derrière regarder on
avait les gilet jaune aussi qu'ils se
sont bien ces samedi à 17h30 regarder ou
pour remettre un merci regardez c'était
super
tél
franchement est ce à moi je kiffe suis
désolé moi ça voilà ça j'adore
voilà que l'on peut comprendre qui est
des gens moi je vous le dis je peux
comprendre que des gens qui ont nom qui
en ai marre franchement il y en a un
bien ils ont peuvent plus et là
franchement le faire comme ça à faire
passer un message comme ça moi je trouve
ça formidable voilà enfin voilà et jeudi